foreign
I started on the show here 30 years ago
and for the first two decades after that
one of the big pariahs on the college
campus was they were getting college
kids in credit card debt credit card
people walking up and down the campus
handing out free t-shirts and free
pizzas and getting people in debt most
of the states and College
institutions have run the credit card
people off the campus they're somewhere
within a block away doing that stuff but
they're not physically on the campus
anymore but we've decided to replace
that with uh stupidity on steroids hey
this is way worse this is way worse this
is this activates a whole bunch of other
stuff that's cray-cray this is
unbelievable to me New York Times
reporting how colleges and sports
betting companies have caesarized campus
life in order to reap millions of
dollars in fees universities are
partnering with betting companies to
introduce their students and sports fans
to online gambling they sold their
students out
in September 2021 and officially
Michigan State University's athletic
department sent an email to his boss
with exciting news an online betting
company was willing to pay handsomely
for the right to promote gambling at the
University Alan if we're willing to take
an aggressive position we have a million
dollar a year deal on the table with
Caesars Paul shager wrote to Alan Haller
the University's athletic director in
the end the company proposed a deal
worth 8.4 million over five years other
schools too have struck deals to bring
betting to campus after Louisiana State
University signed a similar deal in 2021
with Caesars the university sent an
email encouraging recipients including
some students who were under 21 and
couldn't legally gamble to place your
first bet and earn your first bonus so
far at least eight universities have
become partners with online sports
betting companies or Sports books many
in the last year with more expected the
partnership raises questions however
about whether promoting gambling on
campus especially to people who are at
an age when they are vulnerable to
development Oak
and they're under your care you freaking
idiots unbelievable
dude like Dave
I guess it's called it's hard for me to
catch my breath on this
this is the first time reading through
this this is insane to my colleagues at
universities across the country you
should be ashamed of yourself yes and
for those of you who've walked away from
this good for you for having some shred
of decency this is
God Almighty dude the number of gambling
addicts and all this causes So Much
Madness Downstream for a couple of
short-term bucks on the front end it's
disgusting selling out your own students
that you're supposed to be selling it
for God Almighty dude unreal
unbelievable butts kicked up around your
neck and be wearing them like a collar
this is unbelievable
this is unfreaking believable LSU you
ought to be a shame to yourself
raise questions about whether promoting
gambling on campus especially to
children people who are vulnerable fits
the mission I'll answer it no there's no
question about it this guy says it feels
it just feels gross and tacky for a
university to be encouraging people to
engage in Behavior this addictive and
very harmful said Robert Mann an LSU
journalism Professor thank you for
standing up to your own University wow
unbelievable my University years ago I
took them to TASC University of
Tennessee on the air because they they
uh sold out to a credit card company
sold everybody's list all the alumni all
the students and Big Time check got a
big time check to sign everybody up for
the UT credit card yeah like I need a
smoky in my plastic all right well hey
pissed me off I've I've struggled that
cost them a little bit of a donation or
two I've struggled for years years with
colleges who saddle up to alcohol
companies when the students when
alcohol is so destructive across a
college campus and I've been all over
the country having these conversations
with Campus Life leaders and college
presidents everybody this is I think
worse let me just tell you here's the
here's the numbers the number one
Addiction in North America today is not
drugs it's not alcohol
online porn that's right by far online
porn generates more Revenue than all
professional sporting put together
the number two
Addiction in North America today and
fastest growing Addiction in North
America today
gambling online gambling and it's
settled in it starts with the sports
betting is a gateway drug and um I mean
if you want to do it and you're 50 years
old and you've got ten thousand dollars
just to piss away that's fine you will
just call you stupid but when you're
serving up your students and you're
supposed to be they're supposed to be in
your care and they're going to be here
at University president or an athletic
department at a university you ought to
you ought to be fired for incompetent
immediately for endangering you greedy
sobs
unbelievable unconscionable
unbelievable yeah Caesar this oh my God
this is the Ramsay show